[Music]
it's not a bit
i adore margaritas my god question party
is very simple
a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at
me and tarik and we're gonna answer some
of them right now
are you ready terry i'm ready banana
plum asked
what conspiracy theory are you convinced
is true this sounds like a question for
tarik
uh well
the conspiracy i'm convinced is true is
uh
george washington carver apparently
made a time machine that ran on peanut
oil tarik
i thought you were really did you also
hear the one that ben vereen was a part
of the weapon x program
what's weapon x program it's what made
wolverine
but his real name was ben vereen oh my
god
tarek i hate your gut
so bad i hate you so much
is it true or false oh
tarek oh my god can you zoom
in real close on tarek tarik what the
are you getting a little um uh captain
morgan
mustache flip derek
derek i am captain morgan oh my god
derek are you going to have a flippy
mustache or not
i need to know right now amber at the
beginning of the show
you said that i go into this podium to
sleep
and that's not true okay when i go into
the podium
it is much larger on the inside i go on
adventures through time
tarek
join me saturdays at 8 a.m
you guys so i are you considering having
your mustache flip out
i have considered it uh it was a bit
that we did that while taya my makeup
person did
and it stayed okay you guys so
we did it for the james brown bit no
it's it's here
if you like if you want
tarik to have a flippy mustache you
should tweet
at jenny hagel
flip it up and if you don't want tarik
to have a flippy mustache
you should tweet at john lutz
okay so you know what to do we're
counting on you
what are we going to do america flip it
up jennifer hagel
flip it down john john okay that's all
the time we have for question party
i cannot wait for lutz to be like hey uh
ever
that's all the time we have this was
great let's do it again soon
[Applause]
[Music]
you